we've created a generation success of
generations of people who've not been
brought up properly and victimhood is
now currency right again this is an
online phenomenon if I you know I'm a
first generation immigrant in the UK
okay a dark skin if I say well you know
people have been racist to me which they
have right therefore here's some things
that are true people are much more
likely to listen to that even though
there's no reason to actually take it
that my opinion any more seriously than
anybody else's right so we've got
ourselves into a position where people
uh are rewarded for being victims and
their claims about reality are given
more credibility because of that so you
get recognition for being a victim
social media creates the eyeballs let me
get a little bit of attention and that's
causing other people to do the same
because it's getting attention 100
that's simple 100 what about and the
problem with social media right is it
rewards ideas that sound good but aren't
true and it punishes ideas that are true
but don't sound good give you an example
if you go online and you say look you
live in a systemic patriarchy blah blah
blah blah blah and that's why you are
where you are well that's really
reassuring because nothing's my fault
right what about you go online and you
say no one's coming to save you your
life is your responsibility oh I gotta I
gotta take responsibility for my life
now I gotta go out there and do stuff I
gotta go out there and overcome things
well I don't want to hear that message
it's much more comfortable to hear that
nothing is in you know I don't control
anything I am where I am because Society
is this way I'm so grateful you played a
clip of my speech because uh right at
the end there's something people
actually don't know about that speech
and it's been seen by like 300 million
people or more around the world is if
you look closely right at the end
there's a guy who's very physically
disabled and he he can only use one arm
and I'm talking right at the end of the
speech about the fact that I'm not
saying what I'm saying uh for any other
reason that I want young people to get
stuck in to to to lean into something if
you think climate change is a big
problem go fix it go study go learn go
build an organization do whatever it is
right and this guy uh with one arm he's
clapping his own shoulder right when I'm
talking about don't be a victim and he
came up to me afterwards and we had a
conversation and I'm not gonna lie it
was kind of hard to understand that's
how physically difficult it is for him
to communicate right but this is a guy
that believes that that you should never
be a victim to your social responses
right
what an incredible thing to see that I
love that and right next to him is a
bunch of young people fully abled from
Rich backgrounds at one of the best
universities in the world right who
think that they are oppressed I mean
give me a break guys yeah and you know
you know what's amazing you say that if
you listen to the whole speech uh uh I
love how you you keep taking I'm not
gonna do this no I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say I told you so and there's no
way I'm gonna do this I mean it was
shots after shots zero did you have
notes when he gave this talk did you
have and I had them there but I didn't
use them okay so so I'm I'm like he is
not looking at a teleprompter and it was
what nine or ten minutes go go to the
part go to the clip of
um show the one with him and Bill Maher
because this part about Bill Maher I'm
on Andrew Schultz podcast and we're
talking about America hmm
and I said